Tưởng và đập lớn phát lên khi tôi khách 2 mình chính chỗ chờ ngọt ngọt ngọt gặp tay nạn.
Giờ xuất tục xong gần hồn gặp trả ứng.
Tại hẹn chờ buổi thuận lên một mình, ô tồ bị bến giả bớn nhau phần.
Một số người phải đưa truy ra ngoa.
Tính ở trước nhà, có một gì cải qua rất tình ăn là emu nói là,
quan các bạn đã tư dì mà tạy em mà tề giữa ấy.
Em ở giữa như nói, sau mà là gì tiết thiết?
Nhưng về qua là lộsuluk, lúc em đi ra là của bảo mục mầy là trong xà loa em chúng như đó là em thấy có một người ở ngồi ngồi ngồi một người trong xì bò dạ được cố, chiến lời xuống thêm dạ người nữa.
Các con làm xuống người đó, đối đưa hỏi trở người lên, người mắt người đồ người thương đồ người ta không nói được, mà chỉ xuống người đợi cà lắng.
Chị đò sẽ khách miệng số bình thuận trở mười sống người, đưa thông trên đường hả thắng theo hướng từ bối nế về phản dí.
Huy đến khu vực đạ bảo mặt thắng, ô tồ bất ngờ là qua lệ đường dời xuống vực sâu hình mẹt, vụ tay đạc khiến bốn người từ vòng bơi người bị thương.
Nóm hình khách làm nghệ lạc sòn, đón xe tại cảnh là gì để về nhà xấu chuyện đi bền.
Zi chuyện quá đường đần một trong năm 2020 thì gặp đạc.
Theo cố mặt lâm đồng, mình nhé bán đầu là xe bị sự cố mất phán.
Vụ việc đạc được kêu quan trị đạc sòn.